today's question comes from Joe in
Minnesota what are your thoughts on a
credit union versus a bank my wife and I
recently married both currently use a
bank for our debit accounts we've talked
about switching to a credit union with
our joint account
are there any pros or cons for either
the the Community Bank a small town or
our regional bank or a good-sized credit
union either one are just fine what I
would never use is an a super super
small like a one-person operation credit
union because they don't have enough
features to do your banking well with in
most cases be very unusual but there are
some very good very sophisticated credit
unions matter of fact most of them are
and I never would use a mega bank I
never would use Fifth Third Bank of
America Wells Fargo I mean I know why in
the world anybody does business with
them is beyond my imagination you're
treated like a number and they're crappy
and everything they do it's just awful
so no III don't have any money with any
of any of those things so either one you
will find the Community Bank in the
credit union to not treat you like a
number they will know you if you go in
there physically even if you just go in
there once or twice you'll meet the you
know the president of the bank or the
credit union or the manager of the
branch or whatever like in the old days
when we did banking you do want to make
sure they've got good online stuff
because most of us do our banking online
now and so you want to lay that all out
but yeah what I'm looking for here is
just a level of service and where
they're not just so hell-bent on shoving
credit cards and car loans down your
throat because as soon as you walk near
a bank when you get home there's like
four pre-approved offers in your mailbox
and they just I mean it's like you're
playing with snakes all the time and
you're just going to get bit if you're
not careful so stay away from the big
guys and look for a
guy that has a good enough level of
sophistication oftentimes credit unions
by definition are not-for-profit and all
that means is that the profits that they
make are plowed back into services
increasing services or free services so
you'll often find things like free
checking slightly higher interest rates
at credit unions on your savings
accounts slightly lower interest rates
if you were to borrow money which I
don't tell you to do but you'll find
credit unions a little bit cheaper on a
lot of things most of the time even than
the good Community Bank but always
cheaper than the big mega banks because
they're gonna you know they have one
goal in life at the mega banks and
that's take your money that's their
mission statement take your money as
much of it as they can get it's what
they're for it's their very reason for
existence you can read their mission
statement and it isn't serve the
customer its maximize shareholder return
this take money make a profit as much as
they can possibly squeeze out of your
head so just don't do it now the credit
unions are you know I mean don't be
fooled by the fact they're not for
profit because everything that's not for
profit makes a profit
not for profit is an accounting entry a
not for profit that doesn't make a
profit closes so charities
you know churches anything that runs as
a not-for-profit is an illusion that is
an IRS designation it all brings in more
than it pays out or it closes pretty
simple
okay so there's nothing in there
inherently wholly about a not-for-profit
versus a profit so you don't get that
card with the credit union but the
bank's all gripe and they go well it's
not fair they're not for profit and then
well all you got to do is lower your
profits and you can compete with them
tube you know it you know well they were
going to provide services because
they're not for profit well they just
plow their profits back in so that they
didn't make a profit and they gave extra
services to the customer you could do
that is a commercial bank but you know
you're too dadgum focused on milking the
cow all the time so you know you just
got to think this through anyway all
that to say I'm ambivalent between
credit union and small-town local bank
Community Bank regional bank anywhere in
there's fine with me as long as you can
find somebody that gives you the proper
services and that you know gives you the
conveniences and you can develop some
kind of a relationship with I have a
local banker here that is a personal
friend of mine that has had my personal
checking account for almost 30 years and
she's a friend of my family and when she
changed banks a while back I opened
accounts with the other bank I followed
her
that's what you're looking for is that I
have zero loyalty to a stupid bank a lot
of loyalty to her because when I'm out
of town and some screwed up she jumps on
it fixes it right this is what you're
looking for is somebody that actually
gives a rip and doesn't treat you like a
number and that's just unheard of it's
stuff like Wells Fargo or Chase or Bank
of America Fifth Third they don't know
how to do that so that's what you're
looking for good question good question
Joe thanks for emailing that in